that's the first time we've heard that
your bidet is like a sybian if you hit
Vortex is it pleasurable I'll be right
back yeah
can I tell you something that's kind of
don't be eating food right now
every time my stomach hurt really bad I
would use the vortex option yeah and it
would fill up my guts like a balloon
is that what it's for I think so it's
called Vortex are you supposed to use it
to that degree it was an orange button
and it should say are you sure on it
imagine puckering your lips and you
don't want anything to enter in your
life and then the jet stream is so
strong that's a Super Soaker shoots
through how do you know when you're full
would you recommend yes and also felt
like I was a balloon animal it inflates
it when I'm ready I shoot it all out you
water boarded your boyfriend
my butt exactly